hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what's
making the headlines with the daily
mails consultant editor andrew pearce
and the daily mirrors associate editor
kev mcguire great to see both of you and
what is of course a very busy day so
straight to the front pages then let's
start with the guardian which described
boris johnson's future as being on a
knife edge after he apologized for
attending a social gathering in the
downing street garden during the first
lockdown in 2020.
the financial times focuses on the
uproar that mr johnson's admission has
caused within his own party
same subject for the eye puts it more
simply tori's call on boris johnson to
resign
the telegraph implies that the
chancellor rishi sunak's belated and
cautious statement of support for the pm
could mean he is preparing his own
leadership bid
the metro suggests the prime minister's
apology wasn't sincere declaring sorry
not sorry the star accuses him of
believing that rules are only for you
little people
and scotland's the national has the
blunt one word headline liar
well you can check out the front pages
of tomorrow's newspapers as they come in
by scanning the qr code
on your screen we will see that as we
progress through the program but right
now let's hear from andrew pearce and
kevin mcguire welcome to both of you
goodness me what a day and andrew an
apology but also an excuse from the
prime minister it seems
yeah um he uh has tried to convince us
that when he uh entered the downhill
street garden and saw to
thank his staff for working so hard and
so well he thought it was a work event
um now that might stretch gratuity for
some people i know it did in the commons
i know it did with a number of tory mps
if he'd said he knew it was a social
event and a drinks party
he would be admitting he'd broken the
law because uh
we weren't supposed to be at social
events like that uh he even work events
uh you were supposed to look
it's it's a it's he's gambling that the
public will uh give cut him a bit of
slack they will know that the downing
street team had been working around the
clock 18 hour days they were having a
few drinks in the garden uh he spent 25
minutes there but look doctors and
nurses worked round the clock too lots
of people did during the first part of
the pandemic in st indeed they still are
they didn't break the rules and it was
his government that decided to
criminalize it so i always thought that
the restrictions were too draconian i
never expected that boris johnson staff
agreed and decided to ignore them he's
in a very difficult position anna the
most powerless position he's been in
since he's been conservative leader
what's really significant i think post
his statement in the comments and i
think he did quite well in the comments
very few if backbenchers have come out
to support him it's been what we call
the payroll vote the ministers the
people who have to say it and by god it
took rishi soon at the chancellor a very
very long time to come out and he didn't
say very much did he other than to say
the prime minister was right to
apologize he was and also to say let's
wait for sue graves report she's the
civil servant who's looking into it um
he's not out of the woods it's touch and
go it's 50 50. um i i wouldn't want to
put a bet on it if i had to i'd say
he'll still be there in a few weeks time
but if the local elections are a
disaster and if dominic cummings has got
any more
um
uh
smoking gun memos or emails that could
finish him off well that's interesting
jacob rees-mogg was certainly blaming
dominic cummings but you know people
like christopher chope came straight out
of the chamber and said today is a heck
of a lot better than it was yesterday
yesterday us back benches were
scratching our heads trying to work out
why he couldn't say whether or not he
was present today we got an answer to
that how long he was present and the
circumstances that he was there
daily star kevin um having some fun with
it amnesiac pm says he now remembers he
did go to the number 10 party although
he insists it wasn't a party and he
won't resign for going to the non-party
in any case but this is a really serious
matter for him now
it is in that line rules are only for
you little people that he is somehow
exceptional privileged he doesn't have
to abide by them is what is really
damaging them and there's huge
resentment
across the country
uh you just have to listen to any tv
program radio look on the web pick up a
paper people are absolutely furious
because they were sticking by the rules
he made and he was not and unlike andrew
i thought he was absolutely terrible in
the house of commons i thought he looked
a totally beaten man if that had been a
boxing match the way kier starmer and
others were just
laying into him as he was on the ropes
the referee would have stepped in and
and stopped and stopped it that's
wouldn't have gone on in any longer
because no one believes his excuse that
he thought it was a work event uh lovely
weather bring your own bottle i suppose
you can say he didn't know about the
memo uh by the principal private private
secretary but people just aren't on
buying it because it is incredible and
christopher cho may think uh that
they're in a better position today than
they were yesterday very few tory mps
i'd say uh feel uh that way and i was in
the house of commons and you could see
little knots of conservatives all
talking um i wouldn't quite say they
were plotting but i think they know he's
seriously damaged more letters will go
in whether you get to that 53 or 54
that's required well i i agree with
andrew i think if they do badly in the
may
local elections then it will be uh good
night vienna for for johnson the times
have a and a yougov poll today uh
tomorrow morning which gives labour a
10-point lead now that's the highest
labor lead for nearly a decade now
you've got to say after previous labor
leads that size they did win in 2015
2017 2019 the general elections labor
was beaten back but the whole question
now it's it's it's around boris johnson
is he still a winner or has he become a
liability and a loser and i think more
and more conservative mps can see that
he's that liability and the loser and
they are ruthless as margaret thatcher
discovered as theresa may discovered
they ditched leaders in a way labor
doesn't labor's name is a kind of veggie
vegan uh
party and the concerts are real raw
bread meat eaters that's why they've
dominated british politics for three
centuries yes sorry to interrupt you the
times you gov poll gives labor their
biggest lead since december 2013. labor
on 38 conservatives down five on 28. now
this you know we remember where they
were on sitting pretty on 40. but my
question hold on andrew my question is
that actually we've seen the shape of
the defense now from boris johnson
supporters and indeed some members of
the cabinet like michael gove to the
1922 committee this evening that this
man boris johnson delivered you
conservatives the biggest election
result for the tories since margaret
thatcher in 1987 i hate to use mrs t's
hallowed name for you andrew
and that that remember you have to
remember 2019 before you start to you
know throw the baby out with the bath
water here that that is the defense
isn't it to bolster support for him
it is and you know looking into that
poll when you look at that poll labor is
still below 40 points do you see i don't
think kirsten did anything like as well
as he should have done today i thought
it was pretty visible and cheap is he
gonna resign is he gonna resign well he
knew he wasn't gonna say oh yes i think
i will care actually what a good idea he
wasted two questions there why didn't he
actually use his supposedly forensic
skills as a highly skilled that lawyer
and say did you prime minister authorize
martin reynolds your principal private
secretary to send that email did you
authorize him to have that
bring a bottle party he should have
asked specific questions and if the
prime minister started floundering and
blustering then that would have
demolished his defense that he thought
it was a work event so that poll uh of
course it's terrible for the tourists to
be on 28 labour should be on 45 this is
a disaster of boris johnson's entire
making they've dissembled they've lied
they've misled they've not been truthful
and that's what's really caused a lot of
upset it's not just that they broke the
rules it's the way
it's the way they refuse to come clean
and tell the truth and i still maintain
if boris johnson and number 10 had got
on the front foot with this straight
away when kevin's colleague pippa
carrera wrote the first story about a
downey street party it would have gone
away in a week okay we've got loads just
showing people your paper which
literally is just in operation save
boris cabinet rallies around liz trust
stands behind him 100 she certainly sat
behind him in the commons looking at him
i thought pensively but who knows
there's lots to uh lots to play for here
isn't um so uh the metro does the the
two major stories of today kevin uh
sorry not sorry with boris johnson uh
but up the top there andrew to face u.s
sex trial this is well what does one say
about it very difficult for the royal
family there's the inside pages too
yeah a royal nightmare i think is
absolutely what it is and then the
queen's platinum jubilee jubilee i mean
it's been a tale of uh two brits who are
national embarrassments today boris
johnson and andrew thunder and he's
in an incredibly difficult position the
duke of york now is uh tactics and
strategy approved and completely and
utterly wrong going back to the
news 9 interview and then taking this
legal action instead of meeting the fbi
and answering answering questions and
you can see
no way out for him that is easy and he's
going to have to face that difficult
decision does he fight the case or does
he settle whichever path he takes he's
going to lose yeah and that's is rhys
put out in the guardians article they've
put on their front page as well prince
andrew faces the prospect of giving
evidence in a high-profile trial after a
new york judge
refused to throw out a civil case of
allegations that he sexually assaulted
virginia defray when she was 17 years
old before that he's got this discovery
phase or the deposition phase where he
could be interviewed possibly remotely
you know how much of that gets into the
public domain i mean it
you know none of it is uh is good for
him or the royal family at this stage
andrew
it's a disaster it's it's a pr
catastrophe personally for him there's
no coming back from this
uh but even if he won this here it won
today it would have been a technical
victory and it meant it would have meant
that the allegations against him would
never have been examined in court he
would never have been able to clear his
name anyway it would have been a pyrrhic
victory so if he fights it in court and
loses disaster if he fights it in court
the publicity will be appalling
particularly for the royal family
particularly in the queen's platinum
jubilee year think about what she must
be thinking tonight at the age of 95
about her so-called favorite son and if
he settles again that would be a
probably fast expense and it means the
whole world will conclude that prince
andrew was settled because there must be
some truth in the allegations that he
had sex with virginia dufresne andrew he
denies it obviously thank you both very
much
we'll see you for more